Isabelle Adjani serait jalouse j'ai reçu
une lettre d'Amérique grosse américaine
qui a fait
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
entièrement d'accord avec Laurent faut
pas oublier qu'il donne une chaîne de
télévision c'est une entreprise qui va
faire des bénéfices et la cible
principale c'est la responsable le
responsable et la responsable des achats
qui préfèrent voir un beau mec même
quelque soit son âge en train de
présenter l'émission que de voir une
femme
explique au public la responsable des
achats c'est la femme généralement qui
est responsable des achats dans le foyer
qui va chez Carrefour et qui a moins de
50 € d'achat alors Isabelle Isabelle
pardon qui connaît bien les médias les
hommes vieillissent mieux l'amitié c'est
mieux la télévision ça mettait d'image
ça mettait de séduction et je suis
désolé mais ça on enfonce peut-être des
portes ouvertes mais un homme en général
de bien moi je suis plus beau qu'il y a
quand j'avais 30 ans
les hommes vieillissent mieux mais je
trouve que là pour le coup c'est hyper
sexiste de dire un truc pareil c'est la
vérité
c'est pas forcément je suis désolé si je
mets une femme de votre âge je sais pas
ce que vous avez quoi à 60 %. ok à côté
de vous je la trouverai certainement
plus belle comme ça
je parlais pas de moi là je parle d'une
généralité les hommes vieillissent
souvent mieux sont enceinte tout le
temps
une femme
je peux avoir Isa Isa et après on est en
train de mélanger plusieurs choses mais
de raison en ce qui concerne le ce que
dit Laurent effectivement moi
de base qui adore regarder la télévision
sur
le je suis désolé en tant que femme je
préfère voir un mec je me présenter un
grand programme et effectivement co
présenter éventuellement co-présent avec
une fille mais je regarde avec plus de
réticences un programme présenté par une
femme
juste quelques chiffres quand même parce
qu'évidemment donc la chanteuse Taylor
Swift qui arrive en tête avec son Falcon
900 170 voyages en un an c'est 8293
tonnes de carbone c'est l'équivalent de
8000 personnes et après Jenner du
clankardation elle respire que tout son
propre avion à elle c'est un Boeing 747
on fait un faux procès en fait au jet
privé l'aviation privée elle représente
à peine
0,04% des missions de CO2 dans le monde
0,04 c'est rien du tout l'aviation
civile en général avec les avions de
transport
l'aviation commerciale et tout avec les
jets privés ça représente à peine
2,1% d'émissions de CO2 il y a la haine
de l'argent en français c'est un
problème en France on déteste ceux qui
ont de l'argent donc l'avion est un
symbole qui représente l'argent le
pouvoir de de voyager en jet privé c'est
ça évoque chez les gens et ça parce que
vous avez de l'argent ou on vous déteste
parce que pour 12 minutes vous prenez un
jet qui va polluer l'équivalent
justement moi je fais je le fais pas je
vais pas 12 minutes mais je le fais
parfois pour 40 minutes si en voiture ça
prend 6 heures parce parfois par exemple
là cet été pour aller déjeuner chez
Alain Ducasse dans l'arrière-pays en
voiture ça prenait 6h alors qu'on est
l'icône de Monaco ça m'a pris 25 minutes
ah bah j'ai déjeuné je suis revenu on a
les images de vous regarder voilà il est
là puis même petite voiture électrique
ça la voiture est
électrique voilà et il monte dans son
avion en même temps en quelle vie [ __ ]
pardon il est très rare est-ce que ça
vous agace de masse vous ça quand vous
entendez un petit peu c'est discours de
en gros on est entier argent on n'est
pas anti-écologie en France
ça je sais pas j'ai pas d'opinion et je
suis pas là pour juger mais par contre
quand on parle de de de de
l'impact carbone on pense pas non plus à
l'élevage donc ça aussi ça me ça me sert
un petit peu mais écoutez monsieur vous
avez votre moral vous avez votre sens
des responsabilités vous faites ce qui
est bon pour les autres ou pas si votre
c'est votre problème c'est si tu dormais
la nuit c'est bientôt le problème
parce que je veux qu'il est sur ma
montre solitude donc Isabelle Adjani
serait jalouse
de nos jours c'est une grande star je
pense que tout le monde sera d'accord
avec moi
aujourd'hui mais pourquoi mais
aujourd'hui une star des réseaux ou ça
devient des icônes aujourd'hui à Kim
Kardashian ça fait partie des grands
mais tu connais moi
tout ça en même temps Isabelle
peut être jaloux chez les Kardashian
c'est de leur compagnons
c'est à peu près
ça ça Isabelle Adjani est jalouse de ça
et qui est une icône française et
mondiale qui a fait les plus belles pubs
et
et on a une meuf qui a été connue pour
une sextape et qui incarne est vulgarité
mais ça dérange personne ce que je dis
ou vendu par sa mère en plus
moi j'aime beaucoup
de followers n'a jamais caché ses
nombreux excès et ne manquait plus que
Madonna découvre Tik Tok pour multiplier
les provocations
et au bout de quelques minutes face
caméra elle s'est carrément mis à
inhaler un flacon de poppers c'est un de
la drogue qui évidemment dangereuse pour
la santé même la créatrice du contenu ne
revenait pas
enrhumé voilà
c'est une drogue qu'on inale qui fait
tourner la tête
à la base c'est aussi fait pour des des
plaisirs charnel charnel
c'est un excitant
sexuels
bien donc la fameuse Terry Joe le
reprend tout de suite qu'est-ce que tu
viens de prendre du poppers et elle
répond à la fille de la cubergine lui
répond avec un fou rire parce que
visiblement sacré aussi des des fous
rires